you never liked the taste of meat I eat  a burger yeah but like you know the one  thing I do miss chicken tenders I say  chicken tenders  because I'll say this wait wait wait  wait wait wait wait wait wait wait  I was gonna say bacon he said Raising  Cane  it has nothing to do with what you're  insinuating  I have a question to ask the group are  chicken tenders not the most unanimously  liked food  bro chicken tenders that's all kids eat  when they're like Hey Chicken Tenders  you're [ __ ] dude who hates them  you're going nuggets and then at the  very last what's the difference between  nugget and tender come on man racism  it's not it's a purple drink with that  man I didn't say that Anthony were you  talking you were going there I swear to  God you didn't answer the question I was  gonna say bacon